hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen bei kali antwortet heute mit
einer sonderedition manuell antwortet
guten abend manuel ist heute bei uns
eigentlich sind wir bei ihnen denn wir
sind heute in basel in der schweiz wie
geht's dir man mir geht es sehr gut
schön dass ihr zu besuch sein
man versucht heute langsam zu reden
speziell für euch wie ihr wisst hat
dieses format keine untertitel und
fangen wir an mit der ersten frage für
dich rist reller conti fragte jackson
german is considered the sexiest oder
moz charming meiner nein ich würde sagen
sexy kein deutscher akzent ist ist
wirklich sexy sorry aber deutsche
akzente sind nicht sexy
ich kann dir sagen das sächsisch extrem
und sexy ist und alle anderen sind nur
um sexy alexis cabrera schreibt germans
sachs lots of languages du accepted
akzeptieren arturo ist schreibt hallo
ich bin mexikanisch und habe jetzt für
drei jahre deutsch gelernt meine frage
ist was denken die deutschen über mexiko
ich liebe mexiko ich habe heute noch
eine mexikanerin kennen gelernt und habe
mich riesig gefreut denn ich habe ja mal
in mexiko gelebt
in puebla und mexikos ein wunder
wunderschönes land mit fantastischen
leuten die unglaublich viel kultur haben
und einfach einfach tolle leute sind und
ich liebe mexiko olivia stolz hat dazu
eine passende folge frage es scheint so
als ob jeder er meint die meint euch
jeder sich sehr große sorgen darüber
macht was die deutschen über ihre
jeweilige kulturen denken wieso das eine
sehr gute frage wieso fragen sich
sowieso leute was andere über sie denken
mein eindruck ist dass die meisten leute
gar nicht so viel über andere menschen
nachdenken sondern hauptsächlich über
sich selbst und
ich weiß nicht ich glaube die deutschen
denken gar nicht so viel
gut dann haben jetzt markt von maydell
er schreibt hallo ich habe schon ein
paar mal geschrieben aber wurde leider
noch nie im video beantwortet marton
möchte gerne wissen warum will auch wenn
ich mal eine folge in belgien machen
könnt in der mit der deutschen
minderheit ja können wir und dann essen
wir schokolade essen schokolade pralinen
wir brauchen allerdings einen
muttersprachler dort falls ihr in
belgien lebt und dort deutsch spricht
ladet uns ein noch eine andere frage was
denken die deutschen über ungarn
abgesehen von unserer flüchtlingspolitik
liebe grüße aus ungarn von martin muss
ich halt da bin ich jetzt nämlich einer
der deutschen der sich keine gedanken
macht fehlte ihr nichts ungarn ein ich
war noch nie in ungarn ich kenne
niemanden aus ungarn
deswegen habe ich wenig gedanken zu
ungarn leider was ich zur und ein weiß
ist deutsche gegner gerne hin um zu
studieren besonders die fächer die in
deutschland einen hohen numerus clausus
haben also wenn man medizin studieren
möchte aber das abi zu schlecht war
geht man gerne nach ungarn und die und
ja die flüchtlingspolitik und natürlich
die gesamte politik also ja aber jetzt
haben wir eine spezielle frage an
diesmal ja bitte
enrique chores in der ricke enrique
rider und julian manuel may kari
antwortet video this would be really
cool he could talk about the german
football and i just some stuff related
to football
ich liebe fußball fußball ist mein hobby
nicht fußball interessiert mich
überhaupt nicht tut mir leid aber ich
beantworte gerne alle fragen zu fußball
was habt ihr für fragen was ist
eigentlich abseits
abseits ist eine regel im fußball die
sehr sehr wichtig ist
es ist nämlich wenn einer was macht
während ein anderer was anderes macht
und das nicht erlaubt war
dann ist das abseits was ist dein
lieblings fußballteam
welche gibt's denn alle ich nehme fc
basel so letzte frage an dich zum thema
fußball manuell wie populär ist fußball
eigentlich sehr bogdan können dass
constanta lokale warum benutzte so oft
das wort like wenn du englisch sprichst
kann dass deine macke sein
smiley face fragezeichen fragezeichen
fragezeichen verliebt hat geschrieben
wie werden die lehrkräfte ein sehr
schönes deutsches wort in deutschland
behandelt beruflich und im alltag bin
gespannt darauf
ja das ist eine tolle frau das ist mein
lieblings freude dieser woche ohnehin
also generell philips stellt immer tolle
fragen muss ich sagen
lehrkräfte ein sehr spannendes thema ich
könnte darüber einen ganzen vortrag
halten lehrkräfte sind lehrerinnen und
lehrer richtig lehrerinnen und lehrer
aber um es kurz zu machen ein sehr
spannendes thema worüber ich immer
wieder mit menschen aus aller welt
spreche dann in deutschland also sagen
wir mal in anderen ländern gibt es ganz
oft werden lehrer nicht so wertgeschätzt
sie verdienen wenig geld sie haben
keinen guten status in der gesellschaft
in deutschland wollte man das so machen
dass lehrer sehr geschätzt sind und es
möglichst attraktiv ist für viele
menschen lehrer zu werden deswegen sie
haben lehrerinnen und lehrer in
deutschland einen der bestbezahltesten
staatlichen berufe aber man ist trotzdem
trotzdem ist die popularität nicht
superhoch muss man sagen über lehrer
wird viel geschimpft man sagt lehrer
sind faul oder lehrer haben diesen beruf
nur gewählt weil man viel geld verdient
und das ist natürlich auch schade
viele leute glauben auch dass lehrer
nicht viel arbeiten weil sie die
gleichen schulferien haben die schüler
auch haben aber sie haben natürlich
viel arbeit die sie auch in den ferien
machen müssen und auch nach der schule
abends machen müssen arbeiten
korrigieren und so weiter und ich glaube
das wissen viele leute nicht und denken
dann dass lehrer faul wären aber das ist
nicht so gut dann haben wir die letzte
nein wir finden noch ein paar gleich die
letzte frage von tom 1888 e mails zu
gestern geboren kam durch macht nicht
glücklich und mein motor hat und ab
meine familie ich liebe österreich und
meine großmutter
studien haben bewiesen dass dankbarkeit
täglich täglich demonstrierte
dankbarkeit glücklich macht uns
glücklich
ok jetzt suche ich mir noch eine frage
aus was laufen halt mal manuell fand das
war zu wenig fragen heute deswegen sucht
er jetzt noch mehr fragen
sophia schreibt hallo manuel neuer 4 mm
bei der otto james bond germany in last
month werbekampagne im schuh am living
in bielefeld in nrw am bremer exchange
in which is amazing main germany sa so
gut bei den german kam hier sunday is
here are the first thing mann 2006 zehn
priester - über die abreise von
medientitel englische sun beach fan
liebe sofia wir gehen nach wie wieder
fällt und drehen mit solchen fragen muss
uns auch mal weiterschicken meinung habe
ich das nicht weitergeleitet nein
ok tut mir leid schreibt doch mir noch
mal eine frage weil bielefeld ist ja in
der nähe von münster und wir fahren über
weihnachten nach münster vielleicht
treffen uns mal
ich könnte das ewig machen vielleicht
mache ich das jetzt öfter dadurch öfter
in deine show absolut kommst du
demnächst nach berlin
ich komme nach berlin dann machen wir
noch eine folge kari und manuel antwort
absolut du kannst natürlich auch alleine
antworten die ich auch einfach selber
film dabei geht wenn ich so bald ich 100
fragen gesammelt habe mache ich eine
folge manuel antwortet 100 stück auf
einmal
ich sammle ich mich wundert möchte ich
haben und dann will ich die besten 90
aus und die beantwortung leute dann
schickt mal los vielleicht morgen schon
so bald sein und freuen uns darauf es
war sehr schön mit der karre zum
abschluss nochmal liebe zuschauer heute
wenn dieses video kommt ist es freitag
und am sonntag fängt ein kleines special
an mit manuel nämlich 27 folgen in einer
reihe
um was geht es in einem satz es geht um
deutschland und die schweiz und wie sich
diese beiden länder gegenseitig sehen
was können wir erwarten wir können
vorurteile und romanzen aber auch
intrigen und dramatik spannung konflikte
auflösungen happy endings dramatische
endings krieg frieden historie wetter
drachen feuer
ok haben wir auch interviewgäste ja ach
so ja ja morgen in teppich die
botschafterin der schweiz
christine schraner burgener die ist
sozusagen die höchste personen der
schweiz in deutschland
damit habe ich mich getroffen die war
total nett schaut sonntag mal rein
manuell special schweiz deutschland
deutschland westschweiz woher wir hatten
vorher schon gesagt sollen das handy
ausmachen
sucht momentan dumm gelaufen danke fürs
zuschauen
schreibt uns aber nicht mehr fragen wie
ihr seht haben wir ja gar nicht genug
fragen gehabt heute mehr fragen in die
kommentare
danke für euren support ohne mach weiter
so und jetzt gehe ich kochen bis dann
ich sitze hier und warte kommt voll uns
von badstuber in die arrogant sache noch
dass ich in echt nicht so will er in
echtes manuell nicht so
hallo leute
das wird das auf den
wir an